-We are joined right now by one
of my favorite people on Earth,
one of my favorite actors.
She's a very talented actor
who stars in the film
"Wander Darkly,"
which is in select theaters
and on demand today.
Here is Sienna Miller.
Ah, look at you.
Come on.
I'm so happy to see you.
-I'm so happy to see you.
-Look at how festive it is.
-...festive.
It's so festive.
Everything is.
Is this -- are you in London?
Are you back in London?
-Lapland.
-Where?
-What's that now?
-That's where Father Christmas
lives, Lapland.
-I've never heard that.
That's not true.
I've never heard that.
-Are you kidding me?
You've never heard of Lapland?
-No, Lapland?
No, never.
North Pole?
-Right.
It's in English, it's potato,
potahto, tomato, tomahto.
-I love even the way
you said "right,"
you went right into
an American accent.
You go, "Right."
-Right. Right.
-Right. Santa -- Santa Claus --
Father Christmas.
-Father Christmas.
[ Laughter ]
-I love Chri-- I want
to go to England in Christmas.
I feel like it's the best place
for Christmas.
-It's pretty cozy right now.
-How was your quarantine
in New York?
I heard that you were here.
-It was interesting.
I mean, it was kind of --
initially it was fun.
It was like a perpetual
snow day.
I liked that bit, it was like,
"Ooh, hunker down."
And then it got repetitive.
-Yeah.
-And I'm not a natural teacher.
I really tried.
I'm sure
you're in the same boat.
-Oh, my gosh.
I love teachers so much.
I'm like, oh, my gosh.
I can't even imagine.
-I mean, those guys, yeah.
-How old is your daughter now,
is she 8?
-She's 8.
-Yeah, because Winnie's 7, yeah.
You brought a video,
which I'm excited to show,
because you were having
fun with Marlowe.
What does she -- she has
a hoverboard?
How did you make this?
-She has a hoverboard,
and we had some cardboard boxes
that had, at one point,
food in them.
And of course you get creative
when you have an only child
and it's lockdown.
So we made the hoverboard
into a car.
And I feel like
the mood of it
is essentially the state of mind
that we've all been in
in our family.
-Let's take a look.
Here's Sienna and her daughter
having fun during quarantine.
Take a look.
-Yeah.
Whoa, whoa!
[ Crash ]
[ Laughter ]
-She's okay, right? Yeah.
-She's fine.
-That's so cute.
-They kind of got
a few laughs, yeah.
-Whew!
-Yeah.
-Sienna, before we talk about
"Wander Darkly,"
I know you got to work with
the late Chadwick Boseman
on "21 Bridges."
We all miss him.
You recently in an article
told this story
about how he gave up
some of his salary
from that movie
to increase your salary,
because you weren't
being paid equally.
I was just wondering,
could I hear the story?
Like, how did that happen?
-It just feels like
an unprecedented thing
in Hollywood, in the town
that we work in.
-Yeah.
-It's something that everybody
talks about,
which is the pay disparity
between men and women,
and obviously there should be
one between me
and "Black Panther,"
like I get it,
that's totally fine.
But we were in a negotiation
to do this film,
which I really
wanted to do.
And I had a number in mind
that I felt was fair,
and the studio wouldn't meet
that number,
and Chadwick was not only
starring in this film
but was also producing it.
And he donated
some of his salary
to get me to the number
that I had asked for.
And never mentioned it, never
sort of asked for any thanks.
I, of course, towards the end of
shooting with him approached him
and was just like, "What you did
was the most astounding thing
that anyone has ever really done
for me in this town."
And it's so validating
and so generous
and so respectful
and dignified,
and just eternally grateful.
And he said,
"You got paid what
you deserve to be paid."
And that's it.
Like...
-I love that you talked
about that,
because people need
to bring up
that uncomfortable
conversation every time,
until you don't need to have
that conversation any more.
-I think other actors, as well.
That was part of the reason
that I said it, because I think
other actors I've spoken to
about it -- not publicly,
but before I said it --
were really inspired by that.
I think it's a wakeup call
for a lot of people to see
that kind of act of generosity,
and maybe think about
their own behavior.
And it starts with one person
doing one thing, you know?
That's how change happens,
and he was remarkable.
-I love it.
I want to talk about
your new movie,
"Wander Darkly."
This is a really beautiful film.
It premiered at Sundance
earlier this year, and...
I don't know if I've ever seen
a movie quite like this.
How do you set this up?
-It's a hard one to talk about.
It's basically a couple
who just had a baby.
Me and Diego Luna,
who's the sweetest man.
-I love Diego Luna.
He's great.
-I know.
-He's really fun.
-He's the best.
And we're not getting on,
we've had a new baby,
surprise, surprise,
it's like things are difficult.
We get into -- yep.
We get into a car accident,
and my character thinks
she died.
So it's kind of on this journey.
He's the only person that
can see her, and we go back
to the inception
of our relationship --
I know it's confusing.
-No.
-And we kind of
go through the moments
where we went wrong and we sort
of unpick those moments.
Like, the pivot moments where
something happened
that kind of put us
on the wrong track.
That was what was beautiful.
But it's very surreal.
It's very dream-like.
-How was it like seeing
it with an audience?
-It was amazing, because
it was like the last kind of
collective experience
that I had.
It was like a snot fest.
Everybody was crying
and sharing tissues.
It was probably
a super spreader event.
-That was the original title.
-"Snot Fest"?
-"Snot Fest," yeah.
They changed --
I'm happy that changed it
because I think the title you
have now is much, much better.
It's more romantic
and more emotional.
But they were considering
"Snot Fest" for a long time.
-Sundance is so fun as well.
It was great.
-I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here is Sienna Miller
in "Wander Darkly."
Take a look.
-You weren't there with Ellie.
Where do you go?
What happens to you?
You just -- you get scared
and then what?
You just -- you disappear?
-You concussed.
That's it.
-No.
I died. I can step
into traffic now,
it wouldn't matter.
-Hey!
Hey.
It's okay.
-What is this, like, purgatory?
What's --
what's happening to me?
-Just hold on to me.
Hmm?
[ Horn honks ]
-Sienna Miller,
"Wander Darkly"
is in select theaters
and on demand today.
"Wander Darkly."
Thank you so much
for being here, buddy.
Hug the baby and I hope to
see you soon, pal.
Stay safe.
-Bye.